foreign
cyber security is a growing field with
job opportunities expected to grow by 22
percent over the next decade this data
is by Bureau of Labor Statistics
moreover the global cyber security
Market is projected to grow at an annual
rate of 14.6 percent through 2026. hello
everyone and welcome back to our Channel
today we have got an exciting topic to
dive in how to make money in cyber
security whether you are seasoned cyber
security professional or just starting
out this video is packed with valuable
insights and strategies to help you
boost your income in this rapidly
growing field
so without further Ado let's get started
and before getting started if you are an
aspiring cyber security professional
looking for online training and
certifications from prestigious
universities
and in collaboration with leading
experts to enhance your credibility then
search no more simply learns
postgraduate program in cyber security
from MIT University in collaboration
with EC Council should be a right choice
this course is designed to accommodate a
diverse range of Learners this course
requires just a bachelor's degree with a
50 average and no prior programming
experience or work history needed for
more details use the link mentioned in
the description box below and pin
comment and now moving on the growing
demand for cyber security
cyber security is more critical than
ever with businesses and individuals
alike facing constant threats from cyber
attacks this increased demand for
protection means there are countless
opportunities to capitalize on the cyber
security skills the cyber security
industry is estimated to be worth over
150 billion dollars globally that data
is by cyber security Ventures and
according to Glassdoor the average
salary for a cyber security professional
ranges from sixty thousand dollars to
one hundred twenty thousand dollars per
year in the US and now moving on to
building your cyber security skill set
so the first step to making money in
cyber security is to build a strong
skill set invest in certifications like
cissp ceh or CompTIA Security Plus to
demonstrate your expertise stay updated
with the latest trends and Technologies
to remain competitive and if you are
dreaming of earning prestigious cyber
security certificates like cissp ceh or
CompTIA Security Plus this program is
your ticket to success we offer a cyber
security expert master's program that is
designed to accommodate a diverse range
of Learners it requires no prior
programming experience or work history
our program not only equips you with
essential cyber security skills but also
prepares you for the industry's most
esteem certifications making you an
expert in the field next let's explore
the various career paths within cyber
security you can become a cyber security
analyst ethical hacker penetration
tester cyber security consultant or even
work in incident response each role
offers different earning potentials and
there are many other roles also and now
moving to ways to make money in cyber
security
so first we'll see the first method from
where you can make money in cyber
security that is freelancing and
Consulting freelancing and Consulting
are fantastic ways to make money in
cyber security you can offer your
services to businesses on a project
basis providing penetration testing
vulnerability assessments or security
audits Freelancers often have flexible
schedules and the potential for high
early rates
and now moving to the next method that
is joining the bug Bounty community
this is another exciting option is to
join the bug Bounty Community platforms
like hackerman and Bug crowd reward
ethical hackers for finding
vulnerabilities in websites and
applications some bug Hunters make a
substantial income through bug bounties
alone and now moving to the next method
that is the third method creating and
selling security tools if you are tech
savvy or if you have a background in
software development consider developing
your cyber security tools or application
there's a market for Innovative Security
Solutions and you can generate Revenue
by selling your creations
moving on to the next method that is
penetration testing specialize in
penetration testing or ethical hacking
services companies hire penetration
testers to identify vulnerabilities in
their systems and networks and then
provide recommendations for improvement
or you could freelance for them now
moving on to the fifth method that is
incident response offer incident
response services to help organizations
recover from cyber security incidents
this can include identifying the source
of breaches mitigating damage and
preventing future incidents so this was
about the incident response moving on to
the next method that is security
auditing conduct security audits for
businesses to evaluate their compliance
with industry standards and regulations
provide detailed reports and
recommendations for compliance
improvements
moving on to the seventh method that is
cyber security research engage in cyber
security research and publish your
findings some research projects may
receive grants of funding and it can
enhance your reputation in the field
moving on to the 8th method
that is create security blog or YouTube
channel if you are skilled in
programming focus on teaching secure
coding practices to developers or you
can also ask companies or the businesses
if they want their employees to be
upskilled in a particular technology so
many companies are willing to pay for
training that helps prevent security
vulnerabilities in the software
sharing your knowledge can also be
profitable consider starting a cyber
security blog or YouTube channel you can
monetize through ads and sponsorships
moving on to the next method that is
traditional jobs traditional cyber
security jobs offer great earning
potential according to recent reports
cyber Security Professionals can earn
competitive salaries
so you can also have those roles also
I'm going to do the 10th point or the
10th method that is networking and
Welding a reputation
building a strong Professional Network
is crucial in cyber security attend
industry conferences join online forums
and participate in local cyber security
meetups your reputation and connections
can open doors to high paying
opportunities so there you have it
various ways to make money in cyber
security remember success in this field
requires dedication continuous learning
and a commitment to ethical practices if
you found this video helpful please give
it a thumbs up and share it with other
interested in cyber security
and this was all for this tutorial hope
you guys found it informative and
helpful and if you are an inspiring
cyber security professional looking for
online training and certification from
Stitches universities and in
collaboration with leading experts to
enhance your credibility then search no
more we have simply learns Advanced
executive program in cyber security in
collaboration with npci and tripleit
Bangalore with this program you can
transfer your career in six months and
this is for india-specific region only
this course provides a high engagement
learning experience with real world
applications and is designed for
individuals who want to start a new more
fulfilling career and now let's take a
minute to hear from our Learners who
have experienced massive success in
their careers by opting out these
courses hi I'm Philip I'm 61 years old
and last year I upskilled with simply
learned postgraduate program in cyber
security after working 30 years in the
I.T sector in various different profiles
I'm happy to tell you that I was able to
clear and pass my cissp and ccsp
certification exams on the first attempt
after taking the course course I must
say was packed with practical examples
it was led by highly skilled certified
instructors I worked with many companies
before the security analysts and the
architect on a contract basis but I
needed some stability which I got with
the job I just started with Infosys as a
cyber security consultant happened after
I took the course first and foremost
I've been a learner be a learner first
and if you like the session then like
share and subscribe if you have any
questions then you can drop them in the
comment section below thanks for
watching and stay tuned for more from
Simply learn
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
thank you